the Stephen King multiverse is vast so
vast that some diehard horror fans still
haven't fully explored it but we're
going to do our best here's a brief
explanation of the King multiverse from
its origins to its various realities
Stephen King's work now spans over 60
novels and dozens of short stories many
of which have been adapted to the screen
in one form or another his work has
influenced pop culture in ways that most
authors only dream about I'm my number
one fan throughout his work King has
created a full-fledged multiverse this
multiverse is touched upon mainly in his
Dark Tower novels a saga that offers a
potentially limitless number of
alternate dimensions pocket realities
and portals between worlds unfortunately
part of those worlds gave us the Dark
Tower film adaptation but that's a story
for another time sadly there isn't a
Stephen King novel that clearly lays out
every single aspect of this multiverse
but a careful reader can slowly start to
put the pieces together the multiverse
began with a darkness known as the prim
from that prim came a creator a being
called gaen whose name we burst here in
the Dark Tower series hard to say what
Gann looks like for our purposes let's
say Gann looks like George Burns in Oh
God
I could I could even be a woman Gann is
a creator of all worlds the reality in
which much of the Dark Tower saga takes
place but he's also the creator of all
worlds having built the seemingly
infinite planes of existence that formed
Kings multiverse he also created the
Dark Tower a massive structure that
exists physically in all world and
symbolically in all dimensions serving
as a linchpin for all of reality and
it's kind of a big deal the plot
thickens in the final novel of The Dark
Tower series the hero of the tale roland
deschain suspects the Dark Tower is
actually a physical manifestation of
Gann that's certainly some food for
thought
we know that Stephen King is fond of
setting his stories in fictional towns
but our places like Jerusalem's lots and
Castlerock connected to some larger
fictional universe after all some of his
novels seem to be related to one another
in mysterious ways
remember when a character in the dead
zone mentions Carrie Stephen King's
first novel well and the Dark Tower
series King really embraces the idea of
multiple universes in his work
in fact the more he worked on the saga
the more he came to realize that much of
his work is connected in one way or
another as he wrote in the foreword to
the fourth dark tower book wizard and
glass I'm coming to understand that
Roland's world four worlds actually
contains all the others of my making
while writing the latter volumes in his
Dark Tower series King laid out a kind
of cosmology for these various worlds a
great many of them connect or intersect
with the Dark Tower novels serving as a
kind of Nexus as Stephen King's body of
work expanded so did his fictional
multiverse in the realm of the Dark
Tower this multiverse is vast enough to
include potentially infinite worlds and
that level of vastness means that there
must be spaces between these worlds to
King's novel it explores this idea
further in fact the book retro actively
becomes part of the Dark Tower
multiverse and that's all thanks to an
ancient turtle spirit known as michurin
who knows what michurin looks like for
our purposes let's say michurin is a
dead ringer for Morla and the
neverending story anyway michurin and
the creature known as it both originate
from a place called the macro verse
which exists on a plane of reality
outside of earth the macro verse is home
to a variety of powerful entities and it
even helps spawn the universe that
contains kings more mainstream stories
in the first Dark Tower novel the
gunslinger Roland meets a young boy
named Jake chambers who evidently
arrived at all world after dying on his
own version of Earth in the drawing of
the three the second Dark Tower novel
Roland travels through a trio of magical
doors that allows him access to that
version of Earth which has come to be
known as Keystone Earth in the larger
Dark Tower mythos I think we should get
at home
yeah what happens in one world echoes in
others in the overarching story of the
Dark Tower Keystone earth is what we
call the real world
Roland visits the real world at various
times and through the eyes of different
people which helps him gain knowledge of
our world and how it works
many of Stephen King story seemed to
take place on earth rather than say the
Keystone Earth of The Dark Tower novels
we're thinking of novels like The
Shining it's the dead zone carried and a
bunch of others well in the Dark Tower
mythology we learned that earth was
apparently spawned by mature in the
ancient turtle who vomited up our planet
following a terrible stomach ache
interestingly several not-so-subtle
references in The Dark Tower books
linked the story to a few of Kings
standalone novels including allusions to
the monstrous Cujo and miseries Paul
Sheldon meanwhile Danny Torrance quotes
The Dark Tower in the novel dr. sleep
the sequel to The Shining
and we should mention the idea of
shininess brought up in The Dark Tower
film to shine is beyond anything I've
ever seen
there was a six-year gap between the
publication of the fourth Dark Tower
novel 1997's wizard and glass and the
fifth novel in the series two thousand
threes wolves of the Calla and there's a
very good reason for that
in 1999 Stephen King was struck by a van
while taking a walk near his home the
accident almost killed him as he told
the Bangor Daily News in 2014 as I was
having a lot of pain and when you're in
that situation you don't feel much like
writing following this near-death
experience King decided to add a new
layer of Menna fiction to the Dark Tower
mythos he wrote himself into the story
as a fictional character a mind-blowing
move in the sixth dark tower novel song
of Susanna Rowland actually meets
Stephen King we soon learned that King
is feeding role in the knowledge he
needs to complete his quest and if this
version of Stephen King dies Rowland's
quest will end in failure of all the
film and TV adaptations of Stephen
King's work only The Dark Tower and
Castle Rock have really embraced the
idea of a multiverse in The Dark Tower
film plenty of characters take John's
between all world and Keystone Earth and
in the first season of Castle Rock the
show introduced
is the multiverse as a key concept it
seems as though the TV version of Castle
Rock exists in some alternate reality
that's distinct from the Castle Rock
featured in novels like the dead zone
one thing we know for sure as long as
Stephen King keeps writing his
multiverse will continue to expand
offering us plenty of alternate
realities to explore check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]